bonjour à tous bonjour françois bayrou
on va venir dans un instant
effectivement cette question des
parrainages pour la présidentielle mais
d'abord un mot sur l'information de la
nuit puisque on l'a appris en plein
milieu de la nuit joe biden est venu a
dit mir poutine accepte l'idée d'un
sommet sur l'ukraine qui a été proposé
par emmanuel macron est ce que ça veut
dire qu'on peut aller encore vers la
paix ou est-ce que vladimir poutine
cherche seulement à gagner du temps
jusqu'à la dernière minute on peut aller
vers la paix une paix qui ne soit pas un
renoncement qui soit pas recule vous
voyez bien que le rôle clé du président
de la république française
qui réussit en travaillant alors sans se
laisser décourager une seule minute
rapprocher les points de vue de ces deux
géants politiques qui sont d'une
certaine manière dans un engrenage
alors c'est tout à fait important c'est
tout à fait essentiel et on voit que
quand l'europe à 1 le leader responsable
capable de s'adresser aux 200 se laisser
entraîner d'un côté ou de l'autre alors
tout d'un coup on voit que sa voix
peut-être entendu il faut pas
sanctionner d'ores et déjà la russie
pour dissuader vladimir poutine derrière
l'ukraine de toute chance de
sécurisation de cette région doit être
saisie
si jamais il y avait des débordements
invasion attaque agression
alors évidemment les sanctions seraient
justifiées peut-être pas seulement les
sanctions mais des déblocages qui
mettrait en difficulté
la russie et son et son chef mais tant
qu'il y a une chance emmanuel macron est
déterminé à la saisir et il a raison de
le faire et on voit que ça paye et alors
on voit aussi le l'immense avantage de
l'indépendance si vous regardez
l'élection présidentielle et à des
candidats qui sont très nombreux très
proche de poutine très très très
admiratif et d'une certaine manière
pensez qu'il
vous chercherez je suis sûr que vous
allez trouver beaucoup beaucoup valérie
pécresse nombreux mais
cette indépendance à l'égard des deux
[Musique]
blocs en affrontements c'est absolument
précieux et c'est le rôle de l'europe
l'europe sont son ca sa vocation elle
qui n'est pas une puissance qui a envie
de dominer ou d'agresser les autres le
rôle absolument précieux qu'elle vient
se manifeste aujourd'hui
qui aurait dit qu'on pouvait amener
autour de la table c'est de ces deux
présidents alors vous évoquez à
l'instant les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle ils ont moins de deux
semaines désormais pour pouvoir
recueillir les 500 parrainages
nécessaires pour se présenter marine le
pen eric zemmour jean luc mélenchon
disent qu'ils ne les ont pas vous avez
lancé l'idée d'une banque des
parrainages pour aider les candidats qui
font de plus de 10% dans les sondages à
obtenir ses parrainages ou est-ce que
vous en êtes combien vous en avez dans
votre banque de ses parrainages
plusieurs dizaines 80 peut-être quelque
chose de cet ordre mais parce qu'on n'a
pas encore fait le mouvement de
communication nécessaires et la
situation il de la situation non la
situation et que nous avons trois
candidats majeurs de cette élection
au-dessus de 10% mêmes qui atteignent
15% ce qui veut dire quatre ou cinq
millions d'intentions de vote qui n'ont
pas les parrainages
autrefois on disait il bluffe bluffe pas
ils n'ont pas les parrainages s'ils ne
peuvent pas se présenter c'est sans
risque et s'ils n'ont pas les
parrainages il ne peut pas se présenter
et je vous demande de penser à ce que
serait la situation du de la démocratie
française et de l'élection
présidentielle si des candidats majeurs
ne pouvait pas se présenter à cette
escalade et je vous assure que je ne
partage pas leurs idées je fais or
pourquoi n'ont ils pas les parrainages
parce que beaucoup de maires craignent
que leur signature aux yeux de leurs
concitoyens val soutien c'est ça la
difficulté et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons proposé ce collectif
il suffit de taper notre démocratie en 1
seulement notre démocratie point fr et à
ce moment là vous pouvez participer à ce
collectif ce collectif qui garantit une
chose essentielle c'est que nous
apporterons l'assurance auprès des
électeurs que ces signatures ne sont pas
des soutiens qu'elles sont
transpartisane
objective
on peut tout à fait se battre contre
contre des idées et en même temps ne pas
accepter que les candidats qui les
portes soient exclus de ce télé vous
évoquez un tsunami démocratique ces
candidats pour le candidat pourrait pas
se présenter mais vous voyez bien de
quoi il s'agit aujourd'hui dans dans
l'opinion des français et des citoyens
que se passe-t-il une immense vague de
défiance à l'égard des institutions
politiques médiatiques parce que vous
êtes vous aussi dans le dans le coeur du
cyclone dans l'oeil du cyclone
médiatique scientifique médical tout le
monde aujourd'hui a perdu confiance or
le la clé de voûte de nos institutions
c'est l'élection présidentielle on n'a
pas le droit de laisser compromettre la
loyauté de l'élection présidentielle en
excluant des candidats simplement parce
qu'il n'aurait pas dessiner le maire les
républicains de cannes david lisnard dit
je parraine jean luc mélenchon il ya pas
mes idées mais il ya le droit de
concourir vous dites quoi bravin suivent
et sont exempts voyez que c'est
exactement ce que je plaide c'est rigolo
parce que au début n'était pas de cet
avis mais c'est mais c'est très bien les
évolutions sont sont bonnes le vous avez
une marine et qui met une signature ne
suffit pas voilà pourquoi ce collectif
qui réunit des dizaines de maires et
bientôt centaines de maires j'espère est
le seul à même de garantir la loyauté et
l'équilibré de cette élection françois
bayrou c'est à dire pour la noce à
d'elektra 6 point fr je veux réaliser
parce qu'il ya des cieux des mères qui
nous écoutent notre démocratie point fr
et là vous pouvez participer avec la
certitude que dans quelques jours nous
pourrons garantir que la signature
démocratique la garantie démocratique
n'est pas un soutien à des candidats ou
à des idées oui ou non ça veut dire que
la prochaine fois il faudra revenir à
l'anonymat roues et en deux je crois que
c'est que c'est la moindre des choses
non peut réfléchir à d'autres sans doute
à d'autres des mariages citoyen par
exemple mais vous voyez bien toutes nos
institutions sont en défaut aujourd'hui
vous savez combien il faudra changer
pour la proportionnelle combien j'ai
plaidé pour une banque de la démocratie
on soit pas obligé d'aller dans des
structures financières exotiques parce
qu'on a besoin de se financer le notre
démocratie a besoin d'être re est
assurée par des pratiques nouvelles et
plus audacieuse et qu'on sorte enfin de
cette confiscation dans laquelle le pays
souffre parce que la confiance souffre
fabien roussel ce matin mise en cause
par mediapart le candidat communiste qui
l'accusent d'avoir occupé un emploi
d'assistant parlementaire mais ils n'ont
trouvé aucune trace de son travail dans
cet emploi qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez je rappelle que le modem
et l'udf ont été mises en examen pour
destructions d'emplois fictifs
d'eurodéputés keller qui était reproché
à fabien roussel 1 je veux dire que nous
une infime modem ne sommes pas dans
cette pratique des emplois fictifs c'est
un paradoxe parce que nous sommes
poursuivis alors que nous n'avons pas
fait cela quand vous voyez ce qu'il
reproche à fabien rosier et donc ceux
qui reprochaient à fabien roussel c'est
toujours la même histoire c'est une
espèce de de dévoiement
judiciaire de choses absolument qu'ils
étaient qui on est et qui sont
absolument normal un député son métier
c'est d'aller à l'assemblée nationale de
d'étudier des textes essaie de faire de
la politique sans ça ils seraient pas
député et la fonction d'assistant
parlementaire est une fonction de rampe
de lancement pour beaucoup de parlement
alors si vous prenez la liste alors vous
allez découvrir que manuel valls a été
assistant parlementaire que eric ciotti
a été assistant parlementaire que xavier
bertrand a été assistant parlementaire
si vous faites la liste il y en a des
dizaines comme ça et c'est absolument
normal qu'un député faisant de la
politique son assistant aide aussi à
faire de la politique on est élus par
les électeurs monnaie d'abord élu parce
qu'on à l'investiture d'un parti c'est
lui qui vous présente et quoi de plus
normal que de travailler avec son parti
cantonné aux députés c'est le contraire
qui est anormal et qui est immoral ou
qui serait immoral françois bayrou le
président de la république emmanuel
macron propose de nommer jacqueline
gourault la ministre au conseil
constitutionnel c'est l'une de vos
proches historique qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui disent que c'est une
décision scandaleuse et finalement ce
serait un cadeau pour services rendus au
modem
les gens disent n'importe quoi et ne
réfléchissent pas qu'est ce que c'est le
conseil constitutionnel c'est l'instance
qui garantit l'équilibré des
institutions c'est pas une cour suprême
c'est un tribunal c'est l'instance qui
garantit l'équilibré des institutions et
dans les institutions il ya les
collectivités locales jacqueline
gourault vient de faire voter plusieurs
loi sur les collectivités locales leur
pouvoir leur fonctionnement et qui ont
été votées quasiment à l'unanimité des
deux assemblées donc c'est pas un cadeau
mais en aucune manière on vit pas de
cadeau on est assez comment dirais-je
fier pour ne pas vivre de cadeaux on a
c'est une ministre qui cette jacqueline
gourault qui s'est imposée aux yeux de
tous aux yeux des élus locaux et aux
yeux de l'état elle connaît parfaitement
l'état et les élus locaux et de surcroît
c'est
bon sens et une conscience et je trouve
que pour une fois sortir du moule
habituel de la très haute fonction
publique avec lequel on vit dans notre
pays pour mettre quelqu'un de terrain
qui a fait ses preuves comme élu local
comme élu national à la terrisse
présidente du sénat ba je trouve que
c'est une formidable idée c'est un
renouvellement de nos institutions
re retrouvant le sens de ce qu'est
réellement le conseil constitutionnel se
garant de l'équilibré de nos
institutions merci beaucoup françois
bayrou c'est avoue thomas